You are attempting to access Terminal 7 at
Site-119.
By continuing, you are confirming that you:
have permission to access this file, have
submitted your Last Will and Testament to
the SCP Foundation HR Department, have said
goodbye to all of your family and loved ones,
and consent to the probability of a swift,
painful death.
You are not currently under any threat, but
continuing to access this file will change
that.
Please look into the screen to confirm your
identity via retinal scan.
Do not blink.
WARNING: the threat is approaching rapidly.
You have a limited amount of time to review
the contents of this file.
Remember that this terminal has been permanently
contained.
Mobile Task Force members are aware of your
location, and on standby, but they will likely
not be able to save you.
It is only a matter of time now.
SCP-2744 is a bipedal humanoid creature with
a height of two meters.
Its face is covered with a torn white burlap
cloth, with a large aluminum zipper across
its mouth.
Though its true name is unknown, it is to
be referred to by codename “Tattletale.”
The creature is extremely dangerous, and hostile.
It has been determined to target anyone who
attempts to investigate it or learn the nature
of its identity.
It cannot be restrained or prevented from
reaching its target.
Once it has set its sights on you, you cannot
hide.
You cannot run.
There is no escape.
The entity is currently uncontained, but steps
have been taken to limit its potential for
damage.
Only this terminal has complete read and edit
access to the file.
Once someone has linked with the terminal,
all members of MTF-Epsilon 99 are stationed
at the entrance to the containment cell.
The entity may not be discussed outside of
the containment cell.
If you speak about the Tattletale entity outside
of this room, you will be immediately terminated.
Once you have accessed this file, you are
considered lost.
Tattletale was first encountered in the Eurtec
nexus.
The nexus is an underground free port where
a number of anomalous entities live without
fear of exposure.
It’s also a network of underground tunnels
used for smuggling and other unsavory business.
Following a series of unsolved murders and
disappearances, the Global Occult Coalition
reached out to the Foundation for help.
A research team was deployed to investigate,
consisting of Agent Jaime Greene, Adam Smith,
Sammi Radcliffe, Dr. Stephen House, and Agent
William Miller.
Agent Miller was outfitted with a body cam,
which captured the following events.
Miller met with the rest of the team in an
underground house in the Eurtec Nexus.
Inside, he found a blood-stained room thrown
into chaos, items turned over and scattered
across the room.
There was an unidentified body found inside
the house.
The deceased suffered from deep wounds across
their chest that tore off skin and muscle,
revealing the organs and broken bones beneath.
Their face was riddled with large bite marks,
and their nose was missing entirely.
Though there were bits of flesh and blood
all throughout the room, the nose was not
found.
While searching the room, Miller found a blood-spattered
note with the words “HELP…WORKERS” written,
along with a phone number.
As the group continued to investigate, they
suddenly heard something moving and scratching
in the walls.
Tension began to rise.
Was the killer still in their midst?
Did they need to act now, before it had the
chance to give them the same gruesome fate?
Radcliffe shot at the wall, and a rat crawled
out.
They were safe.
For now.
The body couldn’t be identified and was
classified as ENTITY VICTIM 12.
The note recovered from the crime scene led
the Foundation to an attempted human - and
nonhuman entity - trafficking scheme.
Eight missing persons and creatures were recovered
from a warehouse and interviewed.
This new chapter of the investigation left
the team with more questions than answers,
and after an anonymous tip, the task force
reached out to an unnamed lizard man, believed
to be a member of the mysterious Fae, who
was reported to have helpful information.
The lizard informed Agents Miller and Radcliffe
that he had seen something troubling.
He couldn’t remember the specific details,
but a monster had come to SCP-4000, an enchanted
forest and the home of the Fae, and spoken
to someone the lizard man had once known.
He followed them home but found only a mangled
corpse and a room drenched in blood.
One detail stood out in particular: the lizard
man said his dead friend had been robbed of
a name, left “a nameless husk.”
Whatever had killed them, it had erased their
very identity.
Even the interviewee, who had once considered
the victim a friend, could no longer remember
who they were.
This would be nightmarish for anyone, but
especially a member of the Fae, as names hold
a great deal of importance for them.
When Agents Radcliffe and Miller returned
from conducting their interviews, they were
informed that four new anomalous murders had
occurred in their absence.
Each body had the same wounds, deep lacerations
on the torso, and large chunks of the face
bitten off.
This was troubling enough, but even more concerning
was a series of unauthorized changes to the
Foundation’s employee database, which occurred
at the same time as the killings.
Four employee personnel files had been inexplicably
deleted, to match the four unidentified bodies
that were found.
There was reason to believe that these four
new victims had all been Foundation personnel,
but no one could remember their names, and
no one recognized their faces.
The remaining records confirmed that there
had been seven members of the task force dispatched
to handle these unsolved murders.
Four were gone, lost from the world and from
collective memory.
Now, only three remained: Sammi Radcliffe,
Stephen House, and William Miller.
Miller and Radcliffe met to discuss this new
development and realized that they were being
hunted.
Something knew they were investigating it,
and it was taking out the research team one
by one.
Four down.
Three to go.
The remaining researchers were ordered to
return to Site 119 for round-the-clock protection
and surveillance.
Stephen House ignored these orders and locked
himself away in a safehouse located within
the Nexus.
Radcliffe insisted that she and Miller follow
their orders and leave House behind, but Miller
refused.
He would not leave a man behind, not after
losing the rest of the team, even if he couldn’t
remember them.
Miller made his way to the safehouse and arrived
to find the door already open.
He entered the building, searching for his
missing colleague.
He called out, “Stephen?” and “Are you
here?”
but there was no response.
His path wound between rows of shelves, down
pitch-black narrow hallways that seemed to
go on forever.
Just when he thought Stephen might already
be lost, he heard a loud crash coming from
up ahead.
He followed the sound down the hall, drawing
his gun just in case.
He turned to the left and saw another open
door.
Inside, there was a small janitor’s closet.
A bucket was knocked over, and water had spilled
all over the floor.
As Miller scanned the room, his eyes fell
on a limp body.
It was Stephen House.
Miller ran to his fallen colleague’s side,
crouching down to check his wounds.
House’s body was horribly damaged, with
claw marks from his shoulder to his hip.
There were puncture wounds across his hands
and arms, and his leg was broken, twisted
around until bone showed through the torn
skin.
Afraid of what he would find, Miller reached
down to check the man’s pulse, but a hand
stopped him.
Stephen House was still alive.
He struggled to speak, saying “I’m not
useless…I swear I’m not.”
And then, one chilling word: “Run.”
Behind Miller, something let out an inhuman
screech.
He spun around to see what made the sound
and saw a creature lurching toward him.
It was tall, humanoid in shape, but distinctly
monstrous.
A zipper across its face was unzipped to reveal
teeth stained black and red with blood.
The creature jumped on top of him, knocking
him to the ground.
He thrashed and fought back, trying to throw
the monster off of him, but it sank its teeth
into his exposed forearm with a sickening
crunch.
Fighting through the pain, Miller fired his
gun with his other hand, hitting the creature
in the neck.
It screamed and recoiled, allowing Miller
to climb back onto his feet and fire several
more shots.
The creature scuttled up the wall toward the
ceiling, evading Miller’s gunfire and advancing
toward him.
Miller took a step back, but slipped in the
blood on the floor and fell onto his injured
arm.
Helpless, Miller watched as the entity dove
down at him, snarling and ready to devour
him.
Before it reached him, the crack of a gunshot
rang out.
Miller looked up to see Agent Radcliffe holding
a shotgun.
She had come to save him.
The two ran back into the hall, the entity
close behind them, and took cover behind a
large shelving unit.
As the entity approached, hunting for them,
they tried to determine what to do next.
Miller was frozen in place, shaken from all
he had seen.
Radcliffe told him to run for the door.
She stepped out from behind their cover and
drew the attention of the entity.
She fired several more shots at it, then turned
to see if Miller had made it to safety.
As Miller begged Radcliffe to run, her shotgun
jammed.
She had no time to escape, no way to defend
herself.
Her words, before the monster descended on
her, were: “You’re not supposed to let
me die like this.”
With nothing else he could do, Miller ran.
He ran as fast as he could, cradling his damaged
arm, listening to Radcliffe’s screams turn
to wet gurgles, and then silence.
He made it out of the building, where a team
of Foundation personnel were waiting to usher
him to safety.
He was taken back to Site-119 and placed under
24-hour surveillance.
The entity he encountered was entered into
the system.
File complete.
We hope it was worth it, Agent Miller.
There isn’t much time left.
It’s coming.
You know that.
Any minute now, it will creep up behind you
and sink its teeth into your skin, devouring
your body and your name in one fatal blow.
What is it?
Is it simply a monster with an insatiable
appetite for human lives?
Perhaps it was once a human, too.
A murder victim left unseen and unsolved,
that transformed into a creature intent on
erasing others.
Perhaps it was an idea made real by people’s
fear of it, and that is why it’s so afraid
of being known.
If the puzzle is solved, if it is truly understood,
perhaps the creature will simply cease to
exist.
There is screaming outside the room.
Gunfire.
Pounding on the walls.
Protection is wearing thin.
So, think.
What was it?
What is it?
You only have a few moments left.
What will you leave behind once it takes you?
Maybe it was fear.
All of the victims were running from something,
hiding from an invisible demon.
Pain, feelings of inadequacy, the sheer terror
of the unknown.
Everyone trying to run, to deny their nightmares,
and pretend that sleeping with the lights
on would be enough.
But it never is.
The darkness always comes.
Here it comes.
Congratulations, Agent Miller.
You have officially completed the Tattletale
Simulation.
Congratulations, Agent Miller.
You have officially completed the Tattletale
Simulation.
You were successful in acting under pressure,
showing dedication to the mission and the
cause, and valuing the lives of your colleagues
over your own safety.
Your results show high intelligence, problem-solving,
and critical thinking skills.
The test was administered by Agent Sammi Radcliffe,
Agent Jaime Green, and Dr. Stephen House.
Though your work was impressive, you have
some areas for improvement.
You did not follow protocol when engaging
with the Tattletale entity, and you failed
to prevent the simulated deaths of Radcliffe,
Green, and House.
Better luck next time!
Still, you displayed admirable selflessness
and devotion to the Foundation’s mission
of knowledge, information, and containment
of anomalies.
You have been approved for fieldwork going
forward.
Now is a good time to celebrate, many others
who were given this test were not so lucky.
The past 50 subjects to complete this simulation
failed under pressure and died of heart failure
when their fear got the best of them.
But not you.
You have the makings of a truly great agent
here at the SCP Foundation.
We’ll be in touch soon.
Now go check out “Procedure 110 Montauk
REVEALED - Fear Alone - SCP-231 Tale” and
“SCP-1025 - Encyclopedia of Common Diseases”
for more SCPs that will mess with your head!